[Musique]
alors cette semaine 6 17
un programme assez complet je vais pas
détailler tous les films tanguy lé
retour le très attendu la très attendue
suite pardon d'étienne chatiliez avec le
même casting toujours andré dussollier
sabine azéma et eric berger voilà je
cherchais sont donc donc je n'ai pas
encore vu le film je peux pas vous en
parler mais il est à la fiche je vais
insister sur le très beau film qui
s'appelle c'est ça l'amour interprétée
par notre ami bouli lanners qu'on a eu
la chance de recevoir ici donc on à l
affiche aussi venez le découvrir en
salles cette semaine
et puis deux événements cette semaine
dans le cadre du festival contre champ
samedi à 16h30 si vous aimez les courts
métrages et là ce sont des courts
métrages sur la danse puisque le thème
du festival cette année c'est la danse
venez voter donc à 16h30 pour choisir
votre court-métrage préféré ça se fait
aussi dans deux autres salles des
yvelines et dimanche à 18h30 venez voir
ou revoir découvrir ou redécouvrir
absolument voir ce très beau film de bob
fosse aux à jazz en français que le
spectacle commence donc avec crochet
vers 18h30 dimanche et j'en profite je
profite d'avoir la parole pour faire un
petit focus sur ce qui va se passer le
vendredi 19 avril à 20h30
aussi les cèpes nous recevons la
réalisatrice de ce très beau film qui
s'appelle seul à mon mariage
donc le 19 à 20 heures 30 au ciné cette
si vous souhaitez la rencontrer
[Musique]